[Music]
hey what's up everybody welcome to
another edition of
hey babe
how you feeling i feel good i feel okay
yeah because you were telling me this i
got what you do
what what'd my silly soul do okay i
didn't do it on purp
what happened i bit not i was late night
i was looking for a snack they call it
grazing i think
grazing yeah which just makes me feel
like a
animal a cow yeah yeah i guess that's
what it is right
is it made to feel you like they say you
shouldn't graze i think
gray's you never you ever see when i
when i when a team football team loses
bad
but the quarterbacks got like 500 yards
like those are garbage yards yes they
just they were down they were just yeah
i feel like when you're grazing those
are garbage calories garbage calories on
the grazing yeah you're not
but also yes grazing yeah but also you
know
the most in shape people and like the
skinniest people i know and the most
rich people they graze all day
they never eat like one big meal they're
eating their calories like every couple
of years
away to graze probably you know small
meals throughout the day keep your matab
going
what you want to do what you want to do
if you can
is keep your diet in the gray zone
the great you want to stay in the graze
zone gray zone
in the gray zone life is great it's
almost dangerous though if you're not if
you're not
uh calculating it that's why you have
the fitness palette i know
but you got it you got to be careful
because you know what you'll do you'll
graze and you'll forget
i know i i swear to god you have you
ever say i'll enter it later then you go
to enter your calories at the end of the
day yeah oh and then it's bad because
you're not supposed to do that but then
you go and you go oh i just blew the
doors off today yeah
no the one couple of times i've done
that i genuinely
multiple times in my life since i was
doing this fitness brow thing
i've blown my load on breakfast
i've eaten 2 000 calorie breakfast many
many times in my life you've been doing
the fitness app though yeah but now i
don't as much and now i just have a
ziggy's yogurt
yeah ziggy's is great shadow chicken
[Laughter]
you know what's great ziggy's a little
saratoga peanut butter oh
god bless you sarah tokes this is our
our weekly shout out i don't think we
shot him out last year by the way
coming your way very soon we're getting
our own saratoga peanut butter
it's happening proceeds going to charity
we will let you know as soon as that's
available we are literally
thinking of the flavor right now we're
in the throes of producing this we got
to think of a label
we're going to think of the flavor we
might be doing a no press pack
no pressure pack yeah i it's funny how
you literally do another podcast with
the great with our great friend joe
derosa
called taste buds that's about food but
yet we're the one that plugged the food
we plugged the food all day on this show
we plug everything all day long i saw
one of the last episodes with derosa on
taste buds i brought it up because i
we just found out the information pimp
told me i'm like oh my god because we
were doing peanut butter and jelly
versus grilled cheese
right i mean where do you go peanut
butter jelly
that's where i went i won't say who won
but that's where i freaking went peanut
butter jelly
i don't i don't like grilled cheese i
don't i can't eat by the way i can only
eat cheese if it's melted
i can't eat and we'll never eat cold
cheese that's insane
there's never once in my life that i've
ever been out anywhere and ordered a
cold cheese platter even p
taken a piece of cold cheese if you melt
it and put it on put on a sandwich
on a sandwich if i'm being 100 crystal
clear honest with you though
i really only eat cheese on
pizza egg and cheese and cheeseburgers
i would never i've never eaten cold
cheese and i've i would say in my life
you don't snack on cheese less intention
he's bored you don't love
peeling out oh a single american yellow
american and just throwing it in the
mouth
i've done it mo i've done it maybe what
is it surf
sufferers of of tourophobia turophobia
associate cheese with a traumatic memory
what happened to you with cheese no
nothing i don't think that's the
mozzarella phobes often have to run away
if they so much
see a slice of cheese yeah some may fear
one type of cheese while others may fear
cheese
all together no dude idahomeophobia
comprises often irrational excessive
fear of sleep
i've eaten less than 10 grilled cheeses
in my entire life that is
raw that's star in buckwild yes 97. hot
shout out hot 97 shout out
morning show shout out breakfast club
i'll shout them all out c100
yeah yeah everybody yeah star from
starring buckwild would always say uh
i'm in a conundrum he would always say
that oh yeah oh no he's always saying i
mean a quagmire quagmire he would say
quagmire he said i have a quagmire
yeah um you don't love cheese i do love
cheese but it has to be melted
what about a beautiful tray of fresh
mozzarella never in my i've never in my
life eaten one chris
but i've only ever had it on a sandwich
is it is it keto fresh around by the way
well it's low carbs low sugar so yes i i
i've owned i've never i've had fresh
mozzarella but only on the same plate
with a little balsamic drizzle maybe a
sweet road roasted maybe i've had that
twice steak tomato or something on hello
maybe twice in my life i've had that wow
what about burrata
that i don't know every burrata with fig
and maybe pine nuts and you mix it up
and you dip a nice crostini into it i'm
going to be 100 honest with you again
not only have i never had burrata i've
never heard of bharata
have you heard of burrata pimp what do
you mean broad is on every menu
ever it's like it's almost like a fresh
mozzarella it's a creamy
cheese never heard of it you had
stretchertella
wait wait wait wait wait wait because
you know what it is now you found out
you're mostly german not
german yeah you did the 23andme you're
99 german
i never mine i was never in my life
you don't know what burrata cheese is
though burrata like
i never seen it on a menu even you've
never heard the word
i don't think i've ever heard anyone
looking down on you i'm just uh i'm not
i'm not throwing stones here
i'm just saying like i thought i i maybe
i'm maybe i'm wrong
maybe i thought that the people knew
what that was they sell it in the
supermarket the cheeses that i've heard
of
i'm being serious american cheese swiss
cheese
monster cheese mozzarella cheese as many
as you can
okay american cheese swiss cheese
monster cheese
uh uh um uh mozzarella cheese
buffalo mozzarella cheese okay
mozzarella cheese and um
and blue cheese yeah blue cheese but
you've heard of gorgonzola
gorgonzola provolone yes uh cheddar
cheddar goat cheese goat cheese uh
uh uh uh uh what's that other one with
that uh um
it's a little spicy jack pepper jack
jack you heard of that
yes yeah you heard of uh uh
you said monster i mean what other types
of cheeses are there
uh well there's so many though there's
like sheep
sheep's milk cheese i'll never eat
anything from a sheep okay
well this is cheese but what about
ricotta cheese ricotta cheese i've had
you've had that with a little honey
though you've had that cold
never with honey okay okay but i've
never even heard of burrata
yeah well burana burrata b-u-r-r-a-t-a
i believe no never heard of it the art
of cheese making is referred to in
ancient greek mythology and evidence of
cheese and cheese making has been found
on egyptian tomb murals dating back over
4 000 years oh and obviously my favorite
cheese of all time and i forgot cheese
whiz
yeah that's probably oh yeah that's
different than burrana that you know
cheese may have been discovered
accidentally by the practice of storing
milk and containers made of just
the stomachs of animals because that is
cheese is pretty much just
old dirty milk like what is cheese i
don't know but it's freaking good
that's curdling milk except the milk is
curdled on purpose most cheese is made
in factors after milk is poured into big
vats a starter culture of bacteria is
added to convert the lactose into lactic
acid which is also what builds up when
you're exercising and why you feel pain
in your muscles
that's true then an enzyme called rennet
is added to curdle the milk
you you don't eat cheese that's not hot
or melted and you've never heard of
burrata cheese
it has to be melted it's i could or i've
i could have ordered us burrata cheese
for lunch well i'll tell you this i'll
tell you this and i should have burrata
for the first time on the podcast
100 that in a pork chop that's it i just
said patreon wall i just patreon coming
soon i just hundred percent
here's what we're doing with the patreon
too we're gonna make a list so that when
patreon
actually does have oh my god events
it's an event it's gonna be like the
super bowl speaking of super bowl
congrats tom brady
and the bucks that's it i'm gonna say
congrats to kansas city chiefs that's it
congrats
chiefs and mahomes and everybody else
kelsey
and hill and all those guys what
happened was yes
the super bowl's like just in case just
in case
we got those two congrats to both teams
for the first time super bowl history
there's been a tie
a tie can you believe it yes i was go
you know what i would tell the babies
we don't know who's gonna win obviously
we don't uh it's happening
momentarily but it is a crazy story
for brady yes to leave new england they
don't make the playoffs
the super bowl is in tampa yeah he makes
a run with gronkowski
in his last couple of years with a
different i mean that that is the story
you know i mean you know the chiefs are
young hungry they won last year they
have a bright future ahead of them
yes i don't think brady needs any more
rings but it is a story
it's about to happen it's that already
happened you already know this is like
them watching in the they're in the
future
from us that's it and they're looking
back in time this i literally think
tom brady not only taking his team for
the first year uh first time
uh tampa bay bucks first year with the
team to the super bowl wild card mind
you facing the one seed
wild card facing the one seed and the
first time in super history that
the home team is hosting super only that
would only happen to tom brady
100 like that's literally tom brady it's
literally the tampa bay bucks and tom
brady are the luckiest team but then the
fans i feel like the most unlucky
the only time it ever happens in super
bowl history the fans can't even go to
the stadium
yeah how about this one 20 000 tom brady
43 years old oldest active player in the
nfl
i'm older than him wow i'm older than
every last player in the nfl
can you believe that that's insane it's
crazy and i watch the nfl and i think
these guys are my heroes and they could
be my sons they're going to be your sons
no when you wear a jersey when you were
because you're a huge steelers fan um
when you wear a uh uh um juice jersey i
mean that guy he's it's almost
it's portland pedophilia
stage when he was born no no it's it's a
it's almost a crime scenario it is yeah
that's that's what it is no but listen
you know
did i ever tell you the story about uh
i'm wasted by the way off this whiskey
this is amazing do you ever tell you the
story about aaron rodgers
aaron rodgers
if you're watching him we know that you
are yeah um aaron rodgers
is is a great dude i i actually years
ago
i mean i mean years i i i my guess is
maybe
uh i don't know five six years ago uh
somehow we connected
and uh he wrote to me on uh we were
starting to dm and talking and
nice guy that's a nice that's a nice
thing to wake up to a little dmv man
rogers
great pretty cool right hundred percent
i like i think uh like i like
we were following each other on twitter
and i just like we reached out and i was
like uh
he's like i like the show and i'm like
yeah you're aaron rodgers so that's
pretty cool like yeah
holy [ __ ] right and then that's like one
time i got that's like one time i got a
dm from drake
and i just thought it was like i was
like oh my god it was like love your
comedy
and then i was like thanks so much and
they're like yeah i love that thing you
did with eminem he meant to send it to
chris dalia
[Applause]
[Laughter]
did you ever tell that to delete no he's
got a shout out from jesus
no i never told that and you know
another thing that happened to me and
crystalia one time i got invited i this
i told him
i got invited to go literally fl sal
flown across the country from new york
city to seattle washington
got paid a handsome amount to do a
corporate gig handsome out to do a
corporate gig because they had flown me
out thinking
i go it's you know whatever college
college kids party somebody's 21st
birthday
the father of the girl had paid me real
money messaged me everything
flew me out did that i performed they
thought it was cr he thought i was
crystalia
his daughter and their friend's favorite
comedian was chris delea
not me so i get on stage they thought i
was just waiting for crystalline 35
minutes to show i say good night
one of the girls says when is chris
dalia coming
and then i go back and say i said excuse
me what do you mean
crystal yeah and then the father says
honey he that's him
christy comedy christy comedy so that's
happened to me twice
and you and you took a handsome you took
a handsome amount i took to leah's money
i told him and he was like hey buddy
keep it
i got plenty of money today were they
happy in the end or were they like
fine here's the thing but i got to be
honest with you the first 20 minutes i
was struggling i didn't know why i was
doing that
material you know i was like these
usually work
yeah so that's that two times that
happened damn yeah
yeah so so so i'm talking to aaron
rodgers right this is okay this
is right every single thing i'm telling
you not a single exaggeration yeah we're
going back you don't exaggerate
no you don't exactly i really try not to
you can't you you every time you tell me
a story you never have
i most i usually have to say i promise
you
i i take a lot of licenses it's pretty
straight up you're one of my most
trustworthy friends
and the homeless yeah yeah
no but you gotta extrapolate a little
too that's part of it but is this this
i'm telling you right now bare bones are
the story
so we start trading you know messages
and everything he's actually really
funny dude
uh right away we were like kind of like
busting each other's chops a little bit
it was like that kind of vibe
so i go to la by chance in la i'm
visiting an old friend of mine he's like
how you been how you doing what's up
what's new and we're just bullshitting
and i say oh you know like he said
have you i think he asked me like what's
the coolest thing that's happening
as of late and i'm like i'll tell you
one i've been talking to aaron rodgers
isn't that great wild crazy right yeah
funny guy nice guy get the hell out of
it i swear to god like the aaron rodgers
pretty cool he's a fan he likes the show
all that stuff wow wow great
so then we'll walk uh so we're walking
and my friend's like let's go get a
coffee he works
shout out dom di bartolomeo of of of
domenico's foods out in our livestream
you know him yeah he works at the
beverly hills wine and cheese shop but
he also has his own line
of foods great food just look up
domenico's
uh italian foods on instagram and check
out dom dipatoloma so he's my friend
since high school i've known him 31
years so
he's like let's go get a cappuccino or
whatever so we'll walk into this little
place he knows
and he's like uh and people are saying
hello to me and stuff so he's like oh
that
that must does it get annoying do you
like how do you feel about that i think
it's not bad
it's par for the course you know and
he's i'm like sometimes it could be a
little intrusive
because if people won't really want to
talk to you they don't realize that like
you can't stop
for everyone it's taking up a lot of
your time yeah my favorite interaction
is when someone just yells from a course
you're like
hey by the way keep going can i just
real quick we'll get back to story but
just because
you reminded me two days ago i swear to
god i was driving so
i was walking somebody driving by in a
van was stopped at a red light and i'm
crossing the street
and they go oh oh what's up they said
you got that podcast you got the podcast
with the joker i said yeah he goes yeah
he goes i love it he goes what's it
called
uh hey something you and joe gatto you
and joe gotto that he's going you and
joan gatto he goes you and joe gotta
would i love it i love it
and then i just kept moving i was like
absolutely that's it
yeah that's hysterical i swear to god he
goes
and then he just went through the light
so
so i i tell them you know what i really
i really prefer when someone's just like
oh we're pulling up we're pulling up
dm's
patreon if you want to hear the real
[ __ ] yeah if you want to see the story
if you want to see the pics that were
sent
yeah so so this is this is truthfully
all right so
so you have the proof no but not that
this timing where do you hear this right
because this is
balls will be blown off i can't wait to
get my balls blown off
you should have no balls after this well
listen i'm already as i've told you many
times i'm already kind of angling to get
the sex changes that's why i'm doing
this podcast yes if you blow my balls up
with the story
halfway give you money exactly so here's
what happens so i tell him
my favorite interaction when people just
don't even break shot and go how you
doing i say what do you say
yeah keep going so i'm telling you well
i should call him up
he uh i mean first of all if you call
aaron rodgers right now i'll come
so i meant dom but sure
same dude 20 seconds
20 seconds after i said that a car
drives by here
say i go hey what do you say and the car
keeps driving i go
there you go i go that right there my
ideal situation
all right we get to the coffee place
order a couple cappuccinos sit down
we're drinking the coffee just shooting
the [ __ ]
my pocket buzzes i go i look i got a dm
from aaron rodgers
in that moment he goes what are you too
good to say hello i said what are you
telling me goes that was me that just
drove by in the car
yelling at you on rodeo drive i was like
you're [ __ ] kidding me right now
he's like no that was me i go dude come
back yeah
i i look at my friend and go you're not
gonna believe this the person that just
screamed
hey what do you say drive by that was my
idea was aaron rodgers was super bowl
winning
nvp talking about him
yes he drove by in a car and beeped he's
not from l.a i'm not from l.a we were
both visiting he was going to a meeting
i was visiting a friend i was speaking
about him he drove past me in a car
in the state that both of us had known
not to be from
and said and beeped at me i couldn't
frickin believe it can you believe that
do me a favor right now
feel go deep go yeah tell me if you feel
my balls
there's no balls there blown off blown
away blown off
i mean this kid just gave you money i
saved you money does it take a step up
from here that's
because my balls i don't have any balls
i was just gonna read you i mean that's
insane
this is okay this this particular date
was february 27 2017. so
four years ago basically february 27
2017. that was me that
that was me and the bmw that just yelled
at you in beverly hills
thanks for the wave sl the wave slash
blow off
holy smokes what are you doing out here
and then we go on i said
in all caps that was you oh i don't have
my glasses which i didn't did he come
back
no he uh yes it was really so funny he
was gonna come see me do stand up
actually but he had a 5 30 appointment
at this point it was already uh 3 30 so
he couldn't come back
performing tonight tomorrow and then
after that he blew me off but god bless
him
uh no didn't leave you on scene he
busted my chops about the jaden tattoo
and then head to that
for like two years every mother's day
and father's day i texted i texted him
happy mother's day happy father's day
hey and he always responds thank you
thank you oh is that same to you yeah
yeah
does he give a [ __ ] for being a stealers
fan or no i don't know if we've ever
talked about that yeah
but yeah i was rude i i always i'm
rooting for him whenever i can shout out
aaron rodgers
mother's day or father's day because i
just thought it was like i just
i don't know it was just instinctively i
was like we we break
we break each other's shoes a little bit
so i'll just text him and because he's
he we joke he was he was he
showed me that he he would understand
that joke and he does
hold on sal always does stuff like that
remember you met you always
you send my dad my father birthday you
sent him a birthday gift once remember
it was like january when i told you my
dad's birthday is august 1st you sent
him a gift on his birthday wait hold on
you know what it's funny about what i
did with your dad yeah i go um i go your
dad's birthday's coming
i want to send him a gift card in the
mail right yeah so you
you're like yes and i go you know who do
i dress it to and you wrote kazoo
yeah a text message to me you're right
just addressed it a cousin but i
read that as like for some reason no
relation to lizzo by the way yeah yeah
as like like i i was like i thought it
was maybe like your dad's like nickname
or whatever
what he goes by yeah i thought it was
like his last name like
no i don't know i know his last name is
the stefano but like i don't know
i just took it as an italian i don't
know he walked out pimps walked off the
set for some reason i i wrote
i sent it to your dad and i wrote kazoo
yeah as the as the mailing address
right i wrote as his name and then the
rest of it and remember like two months
later it got sent back to me i sent you
a picture of it yeah
i bet you if you look in your text
messages it's the thing i said no but i
got a new phone since then
i gotta upload my stuff to the icloud
the aaron rodgers thing is
is yeah it makes you happy mother's day
aaron
he wrote back same to you sal how's the
tattoo treating you you're a great
mother
and then and then and then then on
father's day wrote happy father's day
aaron
and he's like thanks so much for the
father's day wishes mentis happy
father's day to you too
hope you got a message from jaden sunday
you deserve it
he's a funny guy top-notch guy top-notch
guy top-notch get him out let's get him
on the podcast
sure you know who died oh
you you know recently siegfried died of
sick freedom roy siegfried
oh yes i did know that sick freeze is
roy dead or anything roy got
eaten by the tiger nobody lived but then
roy died not
a little while back complications from
the tiger no
okay i don't know no he's both dead he
didn't die at the hands of his hike or
mordecai or something like that
yeah but roy horn but god bless but
here's what i thought was pecul
you ready did you know sig freedom roy
if that was their first name their last
name i i personally always thought that
siegfried and roy weren't either one of
their names they just
came up with the stage name and they
said siegfried and roy real names
uh they were actual life partners as
well as magic partners
did you know that they were in a
homosexual relationship they were two
lifelong homosexuals in a relationship
together that also dealt with lions on
the side
by the way that's insane to me and isn't
that a
isn't that wonderful you just get to
make money
and may and and do all this great stuff
see the world with your life part with
your husband it's like what we're
venturing it's like what we're doing
yeah
yeah that's like what we're doing it is
and and it's kind of like yeah
it's just a taste though we don't have
tigers and we don't have 200 million
dollars and we're not having sex at
night no
but if you take just those three on the
patreon no differences you mean you
no if you take no sex take away 200 mil
and tigers with sick freedom we're sick
free to rise yeah yeah
but do you know what their names are
that is their real names roy is roy horn
roy hoyne regular which is like two two
single syllables boom boomers
are they american horn are they men no i
think they're german
german and his name's roy horn well let
me tell you about siegfried's last name
you ready for its name this threw me for
a loop and i kind of understand why they
went with their first names only
okay bendelbaum
totally joke bocker
fishbacher siegfried fishbacher and roy
horn
siegfried fishbacher one can only
imagine if they went by horn and fish
bocker
if they would have seen the same
successes yeah that's one of those
things when you go into the office and
then to your new magical fish boxer
fish bonker and horn what do you think
that's a fish marker horn attorney's a
law
yeah that's what it sounds like yeah one
eight hundred and
eight you know i'm saying that 100
mattresses i'm just trying to sing
selena and barnes which is
eight
local injury attorneys that you guys
might not know i don't know maybe barnes
died in a plane god bless
god bless you i gotta be honest with you
shout out selena and barnes barn signing
plane crash celino put a sign up with
just celino real quick
yeah he did he did but what are you
gonna do that's a good point i mean
i mean you gotta do it i mean we're not
judging here to judge selena and get a
lawsuit slapped on us
yeah that's the last thing i want to do
after seeing the commercials they
transition from magic to
tigers bringing tigers around what no
wait
you seek freedom roy we're talking about
selena and barnes seleno and barnes are
two accident attorneys that that made
their made their living in new york that
have blown up
it would be a funny thing that i'm stuck
on the line training
fish parker and horn yeah they they
fish horn one of them was dealing in
lions and one was dealing in magic
and then they met and then they combined
the two that's right
they were by the way siegfried and roy
discovered in paris who asked him to
come to vegas in 1967 and this was just
thrown into the wikipedia
they spent some time in puerto rico and
may have purchased property there
doing a deep dive i don't know what the
point of that was but they just wanted
to tell you that puerto rico they
of course they spent time there and they
may or may not have purchased property
there find out on the patreon what the
answer is here's what i want from our
listeners i want you
to take things that we say and apply
them in your life to make your life
unique and special for example
in the future when sick freedom roid
comes up in your life it's going to come
up
right everyone has heard endor said the
name sigrid and roy in their lives
in seven years from now you might
overhear someone talking about sick
freedom
i've never heard of burrata cheese i've
heard of sick freedom right correct yeah
what i want you to do is
whenever that is for you it's a ticking
time bomb for all of you if it's in a
month
in 10 years in 20 years when someone
breaks up sick freedom roy i want you to
go
you know they purchased property in
puerto rico i want you to have that
information handy
and it's factual and i want you to say
it yeah so
siegfried so oh roy wasn't born roy
check that out can you want to do you
want to take a stab at that name his
name was oohy
ludwig horn or maybe it's you
you ludwig horn it's spelled u-w-e
well there you go listen they had a 2005
animated sitcom
they had a sitcom called father of the
prize so you guys are a lot of more
right you guys you're like more like
sick freed fishbacher and roy horn than
you realized then i realized you had an
animated thing about fatherhood i had an
item anything about father and i had a
pi they actually made it to air though
in 2004. i'm still
i was crazy pilots i'm just so confused
so they as open micros would bring
tigers around what do you mean open
micros pimp
pip showing his age right now pimp is 19
and a half i don't know if you ever told
you guys that yeah
pimp is 19 and a half he knows tech like
yeah he doesn't yeah he doesn't know
pimp doesn't know who pimp thinks sick
reader right now or over my comedians
who started toying with tigers are you
saying that or are you saying when they
were
nobody knew who they were were they just
coming out with we got lions
how do you transition like how do you
get into the line what i had heard was
and i don't want to mix them up but
i think one of them like let's call a
fishbacker was into magic
he met roy roy was heavy into lions
he was heavy into it and then they were
like let's do let's combine them
together
i read this in the wake of sigfried's
passing i read an article maybe in the
times or something
right yeah are there still questions i'm
happy to feel them
yeah i mean just what's the logistics of
bringing tigers on the road
yeah it can't be oh i mean well they
weren't really on the road the whole
show was in las vegas well that was
after they made their boat
they made their they've been on las
vegas though about for 30 or 40 years
i think they're worth like like a couple
of billion dollars oh well yeah and then
in 2003
they did the show at the mirage which i
never got a chance to see did you ever
see it
the show i did not that's yeah we could
watch it on youtube
they uh allegedly in october 3rd 2003
great year accord not mordecai
um montecore attacked roy horn
um because horn held the microphone up
to montague's mouth and told him to say
hello
to the audience which montague found
that offensive and responded
which lions could if i asked you to say
hello and you're a lion you may or may
not
do what monochord did monochord then
responded by biting horn
sleeve and horn swatted tiger and barked
release
and then realized quickly that this
tiger doesn't know english and then horn
ripped and then horn ripped its arm out
of the tiger's mouth
and montecura moved to stand over him so
monticur bit into horn's neck and
dragged him off stage
yeah i know that and i think there was
footage at the time although recently
when i read the article and i searched
for the footage again
sue me is i i didn't find it so they
might have stripped it from the internet
because
it you know the warning it is it is
something and then it's a site
and then here too because you know
obviously as we've mentioned as we
mentioned
um siegfried and roy were in a
homosexual relationship
montecore was uh no different because it
says trainers got the tigers to release
uh horn by spraying the tiger with co2
because that tiger was flaming
so
we we now know from episode four of hey
babe they can be gay animals
they can be gay animals and montague was
a gay gay gay animal
that could only be stopped by you know
getting the flames out with co2 and then
that was the last resort available
but horn's uh spine he got his he's
got a severed spine massive blood loss
and injured all
he got it ended his career montgomery
ended his career
yeah so and then he also had a stroke
either before or after montgomery
dragged him off stage i mean this
bad news yeah but he recovered and they
spent some years after that happily
and uh i think they they they retired
from the show in vegas
but anyway shout out to sick freedom roy
um and here's here's the thing is an
interesting thing here's how you know
the kid loved animals
roy horn said montague is a great cat
make sure no harm comes to manchester he
actually saved my life by trying to drag
me to safety after i had a stroke
yeah and maybe that's what he said you
know and he knows better than us about
that
if he had the stroke i mean from me from
my point of view i don't think that's
what happened but also
he's the professional what came first
the chicken of the egg right what came
first
the stroke of the bite i mean horn i
mean there's got you think horn
i hope a horn and and fish and siegfried
like they had like a playful
relationship
you got to think in any of their sexual
escapades together in the four decades
that they loved each other
right you think you think roy made any
jokes about
blowing his horn and things like that
yeah time to get the you know it's
time to the horn section needs a jab
like that i would have i mean you gotta
i mean you gotta be playful right i'm
not gonna to my own horn here get on
your knees kind of thing right yeah yeah
yeah
no no zero disrespect i'm trying to get
into like the real
sexual play i'm just saying like you
know you have a partner
when you're playful in in in in the
throes of passion it's always short
you know always fun it makes you feel
closer together it's not just you're not
just going in there doing a job no
you know you're still your normal selves
your own personalities i wonder if horn
right was a playful fellow and then ever
never did double entendres with his last
name
and blowing you know you know i don't
see
i don't i'd like to believe it i don't
see one but then also we're assuming
that they're speaking in english when
they're in the throes i mean if they're
german guys they might be speaking in
the german language having sex that is
true so we like to have a lot of
sometimes we like to have fun on the
heads uh but this one i'm just gonna
read word for word at least the first
part hey fellas we're in the thick of
winter and the storms are brewing it
looks like one to three inches are in
the forecast
when you trim that hibernation bush
that's taking place in your pants
luckily our partners at manscape
specialize in products to make sure
you're walking around town with
beautiful snowballs
manscaped is here to provide you the
best tools for your grooming experience
offering precision engineered tools for
your family jewels
i'll i'll tell you what the lawnmower
3.0 trimmer i'm being dead serious
it says the best hygiene tool for the
modern man they're a thousand percent
right i have that lawnmower 3.0
that it's literally to the skin shave
i no nick nothing it's so s my balls
right now look like michael jordan
yeah i'm telling you really yes your
balls look like a six-year-old black man
yes wow the lawnmower 3.0 championship
six rings michael jordan
that's what my balls look like from the
lawn mower three points 3.0 now let me
dance on that i wonder what happened
to the people who who had the 1.0 on the
2.0 i don't know what happened to them
godspeed
if you have that and you love it you got
to know that the 3.0 is what you got but
even better right they have another
thing called the crop preserver
preserver which is an anti-chafing ball
deodorant that make your balls smell
nice and make you feel like your testes
are walking into winter wonderland well
that's always fun i love it
all you got to do is go to manscape.com
hey babe you're going to get 20 off plus
free shipping that's
manscape.com and
uh uh we just want to say thanks
manscape for making our winter weenies
look so great
so sal i really the last like couple of
weeks i've been
really having like a rock hard penis for
most of the day
interesting because i've been using
bluetooth i've been using because i had
those problems when i i couldn't get my
penis up and nothing i do it just
my dick would it just wouldn't go up but
now i've been going to bluechew.com and
i put in the promo code hey babe
and i've been getting it for free no
that's
not nothing in this life is free well
you get five dollars off
shipping no that's not true at all you
spend five dollars
for shipping and you get it for free you
spend five dollars i was setting you up
to be like no there is things in life
that you get for free
and then i thought you were gonna hit
them with the great deal that we have
for them but
we floundered and we're not gonna edit
this out because we're men of the people
because women are the people and i'm
proud to stand by my erection
and if you just go to bluetooth.com
promo code hey babe yes
then what exactly you're going to do you
try it for free you you get your first
shipment free
and and then you just pay five beans for
the shipping
that's it so you're paying for the
shipping you're getting the product for
free you can't beat that that you can't
beat
think about the the ads we do 10 off 20
off
no you just that the other this is free
free promo code hey babe pay five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com that's it what's
up it's chrissy standups listen february
12th 13th valentine's day weekend i'll
be doing atlantic city new jersey the
celebrity theater
then february 25th to the 27th hot hot
hot phoenix arizona
house of comedy then just added march 6
the vogel
red bank new jersey we just added two
shows there go get em the tickets sold
out real quick last time go to
chrisdcomedy.com for tickets
that's chrisdcomedy.com for tickets some
chrissy standups
let's have some fight yan possible and
yeah you're right maybe
oh yeah joe exotic i mean joe exotic
doesn't let's be honest i'm a fan of
jokes i
doesn't hold the candle the sick freedom
roy no he doesn't do magic
no but he's with the animal zone the
tigers yeah he thought he was to get out
of jail with trump but
trump didn't get paid he had a limo
outside the pardon that did not come
through
what can you what what so now he's got
to spend you know a lot more time in
jail but i mean what can you do
best now let me ask you this question
real quick uh you have to pick
one person's hair joe exotic dog the
bounty hunter who do you go with
i'm gonna put i'm gonna put three of the
variations in the same cut i'm gonna put
a third one in to make it even harder
yeah you have to pick one haircut you
have to pick one right now think of it
as like an impractical jokes challenge
you have to pick one
joe exotic dog the bounty hunter long
island medium who you going
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh one of the three long island medium
teresa caputo god bless us she has the
uh
i mean i haven't seen her recently i
wonder if let's pull it up the one
you're talking about is like the bob cut
maybe
we'll gonna put up right here this is
the one i'd like yeah wow
wow so we going long island medium wow
dog to bounty hunter or joe exotic you
have to pick one
go for it well teresa computer i grew up
around that haircut
i grew up in staten island that hiccup
was a bound that's statin on my haircut
i had to choose one
well i mean i want to say that her
excuse feminine at least
well you know who has that haircut chris
angel yeah the angel also has that
that's it that's
just if it's black it's gonna say yeah
all right oh my god someone asked them
to actually put
dog and and joe exotic together uh where
do i go
you know what because dogs is back
i think i want to go forward i think i
would i might take joe exotic
joe exotic looks like i'm i'm taking
chances at the salon right
but dog looks like i did this at home
myself
and i stand by it right so i think i
want to be the guy who like oh i told
him to spruce me up i wanted to try
something different
which i think is joe exotic then this is
me born and raised is who i am that'll
be my haircut
in my casket solid solid answer i think
joe exotic's in a
phase solid right and you you're like
know who you are more so you'll be gold
dog the bounty hunter
no no you're saying wait you're saying
we're probably gonna take dogs i think
dogs is more like
this is all i know but there's comfort
and calmness in that that is true
this is who i am yeah yeah i feel like i
feel like with dog the bounty hunter
all i have to do is if i just cut
the back of his hair he'd have a normal
haircut where joe exotic
you have to eat he really you have to
shave joe exotic's head and start off
right right right
you have to just kind of wipe it off the
map and say let's just begin by the way
long island medium and i have the same
lawyer
entertainment lawyer and there have been
multiple times you know her daughter
yeah when i've been
really yeah very interesting does she is
she also a medium
no right but uh she's the smallest show
and i think that the whole thing is just
cut that part out what's that i said
cause she said you know her daughter i
said oh she's a small
cause no i said is she a medium and you
said no i said she is small don't cut
that but it's
terrific let me tell you something right
now i love a dad joke
as much as a regular joke because i like
to try to make the most corny joke
and to me that's a success when you do
it i've been doing them too much though
lately i'm a professional stand-up
comedian
but because we haven't been having that
much stage time because of the bandy
wendy
yeah i've been i've been floating a few
dad jokes out as but as you know as
regular
on stand-up and it's you know and people
are doing dad jokes at stand up just you
know but i'm just saying like things
like that like i mean you know i mean if
we were doing stand-up still i don't i
think
in my head i wouldn't say oh don't do
the small joke but because there's no
other time to joke i said oh the long
island small
you know it's just what can you do the
way dog
dog the bounty understands by his
haircut i stand by the joke even though
i'm not proud of you you should stand by
the joke and you should be proud of it
um long island medium real quick and i
have the same lawyer is that the guy
from the goonies
the guy from the goonies shout out jeff
cohen yeah and there's been a couple
times where we've been on
calls and he's had to go because he said
oh i gotta go i have a meeting with the
long island medium and he'd say that and
multi what does he drop before i didn't
know the professional business
before i didn't know before i didn't
know that it was the long island medium
uh before i didn't know that he was his
lawyer i thought he was having like he
was talking along and meeting him like
paying for his services
talking to ghosts and i was like my
lawyer's a real kook but it was they
were having meetings like
about big business media makes a lot of
money for 30 minutes seance
yeah um do you think the guy i want to
call him by
respectful is it jeff you said jeff you
think jeff is sick
and tired i'd be calling the guy from
the gummies because if he is and he's
watching him we know he is
just like everybody else um jeff
actually might be no
no offense please i i actually i've
heard that he's a million people i know
his lawyer jeff cohen
i don't mean to call you because i can't
stand that too like one of the best
entertainment
best entertainment lawyer uh i've ever
had have you guys seen this new trend
no please no no please bad chris
that's not real wait real quick let me
just say with jeff cohen real quick um
because you said did he ever get
you know uh he was the kid right right
the truffle shuffle
so when i first signed with him we had a
we had a meeting uh in his office
and he said look there's a picture of it
in his office yeah no no he said you
know you know you know truffle shelf
you know from the goonies and all that i
see he goes listen i'll do this for all
my clients should i do it i'll just do
it once
he goes i'll do the truffle shuffle for
you and then that's it you can't ask me
again lifts up your shirt does it drop
the shuffle talk to shirt back in south
down went over the contract
no yes ask anybody who's jeff's you
didn't ask
no he he volunteered and then did it did
it and he's ripped now so it doesn't
even look
he's got abs so ask anybody who's who's
a client of his
you were like listen you know what he
knocks it out in the first meeting yeah
which is great because then i never
thought to ask again
right otherwise you were just thinking
about one day that i could ask him and i
was by the way i was never going to ask
[Laughter]
so now you can get your house verified
is that what we're talking about
bluecheckhomes.com
what does that even mean though what are
we talking about here okay you can now
get a verified badge crest on your bay
area home
if you're an influencer public figure or
represent a brand
bluecheckhomes.com why that is the worst
thing i've
that is right now i'm telling you right
now this is the beginning of the
apocalypse
somebody's going to get killed the
goddamn apocalypse that they would put a
disgusting
corny blue check on their homes and
identify themselves
and their homes and their privacy as
someone who influences there is a
publicly by the way look at the house
you do
what what does it even matter but yeah
and it's also like
pull up i mean you know no disrespect at
all but like pull up the house on the
right that one like in the picture we
have i mean this is an attached kind of
piece of [ __ ] house it's like you're
verified but you've got i mean
i mean what are we doing you live in a
two-floor walk up here that's crazy that
you're putting a blue check no
disrespect
on the front no disrespect there it is
put some disrespect on guys what are you
doing why does this hold value with you
what is why are you letting the people
that are passing by in a car know that
on social media someone verified you
what does that even mean what is the
point of it
pimp do we have any idea you're just
afraid of it actually catching on right
now it seems like
somebody's just throwing it out there so
it's been spotted though
can you click on bluejackhomes.com we're
giving them
would you ever in a million never the
blue verified badge on your house lets
people outside know that you're an
authentic
public figure why would you want to do
that you want your home to be your
safe space in your privacy yet to
receive the blue check crest there must
be someone authentic and notable
actively living in the house who gives a
sh
what does that do besides identify to
someone
that you may be on a social media app
by the way to be verified you don't have
to be famous
you have to know somebody at instagram
or twitter like what does that even do
though that alerts someone that on
social media someone acknowledged that
you have a business
it's like service safe actually yeah
like what a weird freaking thing to do
man people have their priorities messed
up just do me if they put me on the
waiting list
yeah i feel like it just helps people
target you to rob you yeah
how much money does that cost too what
is that thousands of dollars unsightly
as well
it's a big blue check on the front of
your home it's gross i mean sure i mean
are we gonna start the application
you better believe we are um all right
we gotta get it we're gonna do it we'll
get one well yeah
that's what we do that's why you guys
you know maybe you hang it right out the
window yeah
but we'll hang it right here oh yeah
right here was freaking studios verified
um so wait a second all right we're
signing up for the blue check hello
but wait we started off talking we
started off talking about
you had a bad night last night oh my god
dude
so i went to grace wentz grace and i had
some trader joe's organic mozzarella
okay in the fridge shredded so i went in
there it's like two and
like two in the morning i i had a i
didn't really have a snack i didn't know
years ago you weren't
you weren't waking up to pee because you
don't wake up to pee i don't wake up at
all never
never and by the way you getting up to
get a snack there's a lot of things that
have to happen you have to unhook your
face man
i don't know i i should say i wasn't
sleeping i was in bed watching tv
there's a difference you know and then i
was like i didn't have a little snack
and i
had a little rumbling and i didn't want
to go overboard so i was like what's
something i could do that will satiate
me
right so i took a scoop put it in my
mouth i mentioned my nuts through my
pocket but just know that it's
i'm just i'm sorry oh no yeah you got
nuts now all of a sudden
oh that's right they came back they grew
back these guys lying to me and you two
are faces they grew back it's well
documented that i blew them off with
aaron rodgers uh you're right didn't
aaron rodgers take your nuts
i'm scratching my puss yeah
um um i
i take a clump of shredded organic
freshwater from tj's
like it i put it in my mouth i'm chewing
it and i'm like oh delicious i'm like oh
that doesn't taste too good this tastes
weird though that tastes very weird
what am i eating i look down huge lump
of green mold
oh i ate a huge lump of green
swallowed it swallowed it so then what
were you just waiting panicking
i i was like i was just alone
like making noises like that in the
kitchen and i looked and like some of
it's good and some of it's bad because
it shredded i saw it
and i saw a big green lump and i'm like
that's what i just tasted and i started
dry heaving i opened up the
uh faucet and i put my tongue on and i
kept going like taking water and
swishing it and spitting and swishing
and spitting it out
but it already got digested i tasted the
mold i swallowed the mold the mold is in
my stomach now
still in your stomach right now it has
to be uh yeah i mean i don't know if
it's in but
you have no but but nothing it tasted
disgusting
and i was like that tastes peculiar and
then i kept getting more prominently
tasty
isn't it like bad like what happens if
you eat mold can you die what happens if
you eat cheese with mold on it probably
nothing though
some people eating mold can cause
allergic reactions in rare cases
could be poisonous even causing vomiting
diarrhea dizziness internal bleeding so
just in case be sure and cut the mold
off now that was where i was going with
this
right okay after i ate it and i had an
adverse reaction i spit i dry heat
and i rinsed my mouth out i had the
shivers and i actually opened a small
can of diet coke for taste
right to get it out of the way birth
control meal three
meal sorry so uh but i have done this
i have seen mold on a piece of bread or
a piece of cheese
and i've cut the mold out and eaten the
rest of the cheese business as usual
is that though is that am i a lunatic
have you done that
does it stand to reason if mold is
forming somewhere it could be
forming elsewhere but it's not visible
yet and it could be inside
because i've just carved the cheese
right off and i've gone ahead and eat
the rest of the cheese and i've done
that my whole life
and i'm someone who is a germ guy i
don't like things like
that i get i don't have a strong
constitution
i have you know i have a stomach of
steel but i'm queasy
in my brain right so for me you wouldn't
think i would do that but i've done it
and
and i only realized that after i ate the
mold right i was like well i cut mold
out and eat the cheese i wonder if i
should even be doing that
your thoughts do you do it do you not do
it am i a psychopath lunatic do you
think this is something that everybody
does
i i think i don't think our psychopath
lunatic i don't i do think it's
maybe something that a lot of people may
do
me personally if i had moldy cheese
which i don't really have that much
i'd only call cheese to begin with but
let's say you can't even be in the
situation because you only need hot
cheese well let's say i i've seen moldy
bread
yeah if there's a piece of mold bag goes
out
i'll i'll roof it i mean i'll throw it
out on the garbage but i mean i
literally if we were walking in the
street
and i bought bread and i bought bread
that i looked at molten i may
genuinely throw it on the roof really i
would never
in a million years cut out a piece of
the bread
or cut around the cheese get the mold
off and then melt the ch
i would never in a million years do that
so i am
i'm trish i won't take medicine or drink
milk a day after the expiration date i
won't do it
i'd rather just go buy new milk and go
buy new medicine
no that's that's the devil's biggest
scam that's the devil's biggest scam
right there
first of all milk just smell it milk and
eggs
eggs they take can go three to four
weeks past the expiration really yeah
this is just big farm wanting you to
turn over what about what about milk
milk smells good i do it but
tylenol they all put a one-year stamp on
it
i believe that at most maybe you lose a
small percentage of potency boom that's
it
read it it's true it's true
the effectiveness of a drug may decrease
over time but much of the original
potency still remains even a decade
after the expiration date inc excluding
nitroglycerin
insulin and liquid antibiotics most
medications are as long lasting
as the ones tested by the milk you see
what i'm saying they just want you to
buy new [ __ ] they want you to go back to
the doctor they want you to pay a copay
again they want the insurance to get
up you keep taking medicine well no no
no
no throw your medicine out at the
expiration date
and then if you want to do something you
you decide to do it i didn't tell you
to do anything there's been i began
there's been multiple times in my life
where i've been sick
and then went into the cupboard chrissy
cupbert
and looked for medicine and seeing that
the medicine was
not that much past the expiration date
maybe a year a couple of months before
expiration date and went back into bed
and stayed sick and wouldn't take the
medicine what do you think until i could
go the next day i don't know
i don't know talk me through what your
thought process is i don't even do this
do you think
that it might have like um medi like
scientifically
expired and then possibly become
poisonous i don't know what it is but
with medicine
perfect example a month ago oh a month
ago a week ago
i had a really bad stomach ache i had a
really bad stomachache like you know bad
i'm like
oh i know pepto-bismol will help me i go
to the cupboard yeah
i pull it out i pull out pepto-bismol
the only pepto-bismol i have
is kids pepto-bismol so i say to jasmine
i'm like can i
a weak a weaker strength well i said i
said can i take kids pepto-bismol she
was like
yeah why don't you be able to take kids
pepto-bismol i said well it's for kids
she's like well you were a kid once
i was like yeah but i'm not a kid now
right and she said yeah i'm almost
positive you can take kids pepto-bismol
she was like just take three of them it
says take two of them
yeah i looked at it put it back wouldn't
take the medicine
because it said kids i don't know i just
sat down and said it's not for me
but i don't know after talking it out
with you and thinking about it
it's like of course i could take a
children's medicine but i did
i thought i don't know because i don't
know the way medicines work and i don't
know if like sure you always pump the
brakes when it has to do with
medicine but medicine i just don't know
but i've never taken
anything that's passed the expiration
date or not meant for me like for
example if you were a doctor would you
eat a luna bar
yeah a luna bar is formulated for women
i use women the whole thing so do i i
use women's deodorant too i'm wearing
women
right now women's spray dove deodorant i
use secret strong enough for a man ph
bounce for a woman made for a woman yeah
strong enough for a man made for a woman
yeah that's right
interesting so you're fine with women's
deodorant
but when it comes to but luna bars are
made for women
which is really odd to me that they cut
out half the they
have the potential is there something in
there like does you know i'm wild i buy
it anyway you buy it anyway yeah i'll
tell you what
for i would say now two and a half weeks
i guess
as you know i've said my uh my
girlfriend's pregnant due date july 4th
um i for multiple weeks just because i
wasn't looking i kept taking them from
the back
i was taking her prenatal vitamins
thinking it was my men's multivitamins
okay so i
i've taken two weeks now mood swings
i'm loaded with folic acid i'm growing a
uterus i've taken i've taken our
prenatal vitamins for two weeks
truly two weeks all right so and you
didn't know
i yeah because i i would just grab it
and then like basically in in the in the
i've said cupboard now by the way is any
other podcast i've said cupboard now
three times yeah in less than
two minutes so i'll say it one more time
and then we're gonna move on from it you
went in you grabbed your cards
from the cupboard yeah so and i would
pull out i would just pop
pop it open from the back take one and
then but always the label probably
though it was just a multi yeah prenatal
not a prenatal yeah i thought it was the
same and then
what is in the prenatal i think it's
folic acid is the big thing
folic acid which prenatal vitamins are
specific to the needs of pregnant and
breastfeeding women
um they're geared to make up the common
nutritional deficiencies
a pregnant woman could have but they
aren't really intended for women or men
who aren't expecting or lactating
so that was a mistake well if i'm saying
it now
for being hundred percent honest with
you i'm not expecting but i am lactating
so that's the thing that happens in
pregnancy not that they liked it but
they i i saw this recently
the the the breasts just stopped leaking
uh yeah
but just start leaking oh yeah no she if
she goes like this right now she can
squirt it at me like like a
water that's wild though it's like
wikileaks it's like titty leaks i drank
i drank breast milk before just
to give it a taste just to give it a
taste like whether she wants that stuff
coming out or not it's going to leak
it's like it's going to link it's coming
out
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah he didn't
did he get pardoned
no don't 10 amazing facts you probably
didn't know about pregnancy your heart
actually grows
wow your partner may experience
pregnancy symptoms i feel that
i feel i'm i'm having symptom symptoms
that she's having i'm having them like i
have pregnancy brain
i feel like there's times where she's
like oh i got pain in my uterus and i
feel pain and wear a uterus of if i have
one
what would be what is pregnancy brain
just like absolutely crazy brain is like
you can't think of something in scatter
brain and you feel so
your brain feels so mentally exhausted
yeah i swear to god i feel that
um babies crying the womb you can crave
non-food items
it's possible to be pregnant for over a
year let's break these down one by one
if you have any interest please
you can crave you can crave non-food
items what would you crave as a non-food
item
like you just crave a baseball
yeah like i just crave an official major
league baseball yeah
yeah i explained to you i'm pregnant
yeah it's like you're just craving like
i'm craving gary sinise movies
[Laughter]
okay i guess so saying they crave soap
chalk or paper and stones
that's sorry that's hey babe crazy
she wanted to eat paper the other day
she had a desire to chew paper i swear
to god
she wanted to chew paper that's nuts
no paper she asked me that's
odd she said to me she goes you know
what's so crazy right now she goes can
you go to the printer and get me some
piece of paper
i swear and i said
and i said yeah you're going to do arts
and crafts and delilah she goes no i
just want to chew on it
holy cow it's real that's real i can't
believe we just saw that that's real
he she came back you you were chewing on
a gary sinise movie
yeah she was eating my freaking dvds
yeah she ate she ate all the merch for
my shows coming up in atlantic city
february 12-13 atlantic city theater
christy comedy for ticks
comedy.com that's it yeah um the longest
pregnancy ever recorded was pregnancy of
a woman
named balloula bulla hunter from los
angeles that's beulah you know how i
know that honey
that's the name of an elephant that had
no joke
no joke we had an elephant like season
one of the show they hid my car keys in
the middle of elephant [ __ ]
and i had to stand the elephant was
standing right next to me and i had to
go through all the elven [ __ ] to find my
car keys
the elephant's name was beulah beulah
yeah well and and speak and
elephants have very long pregnancies
this woman beulah
12 and a half month long or whopping
three months longer than the average
pregnancy god
i don't know how or why that happened
whoa
a 12 and a half month pregnancy that's a
lot like the kids just like
in there wearing dungarees already well
really a lot of people say pregnancies
are nine months but it's really 10
months
when you're when it's ten months
pregnancy i don't know why we don't go
nine months when they're born why don't
we be like ugh
you're 10 months old yeah right instead
of zero
yeah so really right now you're 35 and
10 months or whatever
i'm 36 i'm closer to 37 than i think
right right
interesting so it was so yeah so we were
going back so so go back to okay so
that's a non-cr non-food item but
if we can go back to the things that
happened during pregnancy because there
was one after that
that list you had well it said it said
yeah you it's possibly pregnant for over
a year okay
babies cry in the womb okay whatever
your feet can grow up to one full size
that all makes sense to me
okay taller women are more likely to
conceive twins that's wild
what's the reason there maybe more of a
protein maybe if they have more of a i
bet you some type of protein that makes
them tall so like the wnba just
shooting out twins twins all day yeah oh
yeah there you go certain protein
released from the liver that is linked
to increased ovulation yeah i knew it
was something
over five foot five i guess that's tall
i mean i guess that's tall
by the way i i think i i i there's one
scientific
what is it there is one scientifically
proven meant to bring on labor wacky
methods of labor passed down through
generations there's actually one which
has been significantly proven to work
nipple stimulation tricks your body into
thinking you're feeding your baby
here's the thing i i've told this before
i may have told this on this podcast
but i've told this when delilah my
daughter was being born she was four
days late
the the doula yeah the door the doula
was like
you know like a jewish um like midwife
told me and my girl they were like the
only way if you want to increa if you
want to induce labor
in the next hour then what you need to
do is swallow his semen
that's what you need to do swear to god
her response was she goes you have to be
kidding me she goes
did he pay you to say that that's what
she said
how's that possible she said because
there's properties when when semen is
ingested
but straight face wanted you to do that
little jewish woman says if you want to
have the baby if you want to go into
labor soon what you need to do is
swallow his semen
and she was like trust me the baby will
be born within the next 10 hours
you can i'll you can call her up and ask
you guys like we're gonna take we're
gonna respectfully
take a pass we were in the middle of a
we were in the hospital right so
i said how am i supposed to do that
right right and
literally time is going by time's gone
by time's gone by an hour two hours
and i kept saying like you know
i'm like we could put this to bed right
now put this to bed right now i said i'm
ready to go
she said no no no i'm not to do it i
would say maybe five hours after that
she finally looks like started going
labor and water broke but she told me
then after she gave birth she was like
you maybe had 20 more minutes she said i
would have just
she's like i would have done it in front
of your mother that's what she said
she said i don't care she was like i
needed to get this baby out yeah
yeah so all right so there you go now
what what's your take on me
carving mold out of the cheese to eat
the remaining cheese don malt
i think that you carving the mold out to
eat the remaining of the cheese
i think that you it's bad you're a tough
guy
to pin down because it's like you said
for as germ
as much of a germaphobe as you can you
know admittingly be
the fact that you're going to eat
potentially molded cheese yeah it's
crazy that i do that
makes me think what what do you actually
care about i just feel
i don't like to be wasteful that's where
it's coming from it's believe me i said
i was it's like i was born during the
great depression or something oh you
could have been by the way watching a
little show on netflix called chasing
death
episode reincarnation you may very well
be from the reincar is that right
you may very well be from the great
depression era okay very possible
whatever you feel connected to yeah i
feel a guilt in wasting stuff like okay
when i walk out of a room i shut the
light
i won't leave a running faucet on you
have you've had a dead goldfish in your
freeze for eight years there you go
and another thing is like i'll keep
everything goes in the fridge as
leftovers
right and then i i will always try to
get the leftovers done before i get new
i just don't like to be wasteful
it's interesting too because mold is a
type of fungus that's used in like
antibiotics so you would think if you're
eating
penicillin right yeah wouldn't you think
like if you're if you're if you have an
infection like right now i have an
infection on my finger i could just go
eat a bunch of your moldy cheese
and clear the infection you know we
should try it
i'm down i don't know if i threw it out
what if you sm
smear all the green mold all over your
open wound
let's do it for the patreon by the way
did i ever tell you the story of when i
got an infection of my finger in england
and what happened
i don't believe so okay i by the way
this is this for anybody
and i get that excited i get any
everybody has different stories for for
whatever i get that
literally i would there he goes i was
certainly 100 uh this is a two-part
story i think the second part you've
heard
yeah i went to england london
biting my nails nervous on the flight a
couple days go by i get an infection in
my finger to the point where i can't
even
bend my hand it's painful i had red
streak it's like a serious infection it
it was crazy i'm on the other side i'm
across the pond yeah
i'm saying you know anybody out there
who says oh america has the best
healthcare system
you know uh national healthcare doesn't
work you got to wait what it
fine everyone has their own personal
stories fine fight fine i'm telling you
my story with national healthcare
was on was the the service i got was so
crazy that i thought maybe it was some
kind of scheme and i wasn't in a
hospital and i was going to be robbed or
i was on some type of prank show
because it was good it would here's what
happened i go in
it was my right hand i had an infection
in my finger like you can't imagine like
i said i couldn't throbbing
i couldn't move my hand at the wrist
that's how
it was swollen so i had i had to if it
cost me
you could inhale a cab no chance i
couldn't hail anything
so so um um people always
you guys are so mad that we edit cursing
trying it
hey babe that's it suck it we curse
everyone curses we hit curses old dog
you need to hear the cursing yeah
i want to go right back to this but you
guys with the like i don't know
the cursing i need to hear the curses it
doesn't
matter you stupid piece of [ __ ]
there it is like it doesn't even matter
we cursed all us all we're trying to do
is just like hey
i don't want to hear maybe we're just
trying something we're just trying
something different
you know the algorithm doesn't look at
the 30 seconds
the other people curse and they still
get the same ads and who cares
yes refocus your energy reprioritize
you need to hear me safe
so so with so with my infected finger i
go in there
i can't write with my right hand you
know because my right hand
genuinely doesn't work i have to try to
fill out this form with the left
hand so there's a nurse you know there
or like a i think she was a nurse she
was dressed in herself but right there
there was
basically nobody in the in the emergency
room i think she was a nurse
she had the nurse hat on she's like she
worked at an in-n-out burger spy
and there's just my she was thinking she
was in her shoes well she's the old
school nurse
with that hat that looked like she
worked at in-n-out burgers
so like mrs ratchet yeah mrs roberts
ratchet great show
shout out is that sora sarah paulson oh
okay
netflix she's great great i almost
confused her with the
nurse jackie eddie falconi falco who
who's god bless her i know edie was on
our show recently
great stupendous guest brain's good
right
yes yes also shout out uh
catherine narducci who was the uh
actress italian actor you've seen in
many things
also was the wife of robert de niro in
bronx tale uh for the last few years has
been commenting on my instagram thinking
i'm a fully open homosexual man
so shout out captain rdj mentioned that
for the first time last week i don't
know she told the homeless pimp she's
like i know that guy she's like you know
your friend chris he's great a gay
comedian i support him
she's like he's not gay he's kind of why
he's got kids
um but thanks shout out captain i'm
teaching um that doesn't mean a lot i
know a lot of guys that have kids that
are gay
drew well i know three yeah my i have an
uncle gay
um kids so so um uh so i go
i go to the to the a e it's called
ambulance
i i i just imagine him introducing
himself like that yeah
how are you doing charles gay three kids
yeah what it is yeah
yeah how you doing so i go in and i say
i say to her she says oh
you fill out this form so so i say i say
the problem is ma'am i said two things
one i'm an american citizen i have a
passport to prove that
she's just looking at me she's like okay
and then two i said i can't fill out the
form because i can't write left and she
goes
dude do what you can love so i literally
wrote
like it looked like i wrote my name
backwards i could barely do it i was
writing it lefty i didn't even put in my
address
i i swear to god for residents i just
put usa
okay because i couldn't right with the
hand and then they called me in
the doctor called me in but not even in
so
let me try to explain this i'm filling
out the form to the right of the left of
the desk
filling out the nurses look at me i'm
writing usa my name backwards the k you
know
christopher with a k like a
five-year-old the doctor
calls me from the other side of the desk
and says
um next patient please next patient
please
and there's nobody around there's nobody
around so i said is that me i said i
haven't filled out the form yet
he goes don't worry about it so i walk
to him
literally i'm still out in the waiting
room imagine in the waiting room of a
hospital that nobody's in and there's a
nurse i think is a nurse dressed like
she's serving in
out burgers and then a doctor yes and he
goes what's the problem
so i i showed him my hand and i said i i
was biting my nails on the plane which i
know i'm not supposed to do
i over explaining i said no i'm supposed
to do it's a bad habit my mother's been
telling me stop doing for years
i said but now i have an infection in my
hand and my hand and wrists are swollen
he goes i can see that very clearly and
i said
so what you know like should we go in
the back or whatever he goes well are
you allergic
to uh any types of medication
antibiotics penicillin anything
and i said i could listen to this all
day yeah i swear to god we'll talk about
that
yeah i said i said no i'm not he goes
okay
he goes well what we're gonna do first
is he goes first i have to lance it
and he said it like that never forget he
said lance he said first i'm gonna have
to
lance it he said so what i'm gonna do is
i'm gonna put a little
he's got he said he's gonna put
penicillin on the tip and then he
literally uh sal did you have to
understand one thing what i'm telling
you
i i'm literally i'm standing i hand to
god i forgot what the name of the
hospital was but it was in
somewhere in london htg i'm standing
somewhere in london in a hospital
the doctor it's it's it's the the
waiting room a vending machine
and the doctor with the lance with
penicillin at the tip of it lancing my
finger
then giving so with penicillin on it
then he gave me
no pharmacy no nothing like that gives
me
pills right there 14 days of pills
he says 40 days of antibiotic pills plus
pepto-bismol or their ver the the
pepto-bismol
i forgot what it's called it's like bism
yeah something bismuth pepto-bismol but
yeah but bismuth
but yeah but that's but there's points
of the story to that so he gives me that
he gives me the bismuth and he gives me
and he says if come back in two days if
you have any type of
allergic reaction he goes we'll give you
another medicine that's it
so i'm like i'm like that's it like
whatever he goes that's it
so as i'm walking out i'm leaving the
woman says oh love love love love
come back she goes you forgot you've
forgotten something and i said
and i said i said oh yeah i have usa
written you know and you know
i'm sure there's a co-pay she goes oh no
no no she goes we give you money
they gave me twenty dollars to take a
cab home
from the hospital no i swear to god
that's all you
that's what they did in england i don't
have to go to a pharmacy i don't have to
give a prescription or do anything like
that
i wasn't even a cit i wrote usa uh of
where i live
they don't even know my name what are we
doing what are we doing here
they gave me 20 to take an uber home i
took the medication
like i took the antibiotics a day later
my finger and wrists are half the size
three days later i'm back fully jerking
off no problem
and you and how much was the uber the
uber was it less than twenty dollars
i made another deal he bought me lunch
then i'm going to heathrow airport
just in case because i didn't trust
because how i told you i don't trust
medications with the expiration date i
won't even take a pepto-bismol kids
i said i'm not taking this funky-ass
british version of pepto-bismol
right whatever this doctor gave me who
just you know him and nurse him in the
in and out lady gave me the the
the the treatment on the other side of
the counter yeah i went
and i found a store that had
pepto-bismol
because i wanted pepto-bishop pepto
actually i'm sorry
what what did pepto-bismol have to do
with the cut on your finger
in case i had diarrhea from the
antibiotics they gave me a something to
help my stomach got it so i get to
pepto-bismol
i get the pepto-bismol i take your time
yeah because it's bringing back memories
they just they get extra content i i
i go to pepto-bismol i you know take it
just in case coat the stomach
put it in my bag forget about it going
to heathrow airport
i don't know whenever i leave three days
later four days later packed heathrow
airport london
packed south like you can't imagine like
squirting around the lines
going around the lines yeah going around
the lines you know whatever
all of a sudden get there packed bag
of course put the bag through gets
flagged of course gets flagged
i'm like what the hell do i have and i
don't have anything in it like it's just
like annoying like whatever like i think
you're gonna miss your flight pack
the you know tsa equivalent in england
comes over starts rummaging through the
bag
it's you know pulling things out pulls
out the pepto-bismol goes what's this
and i said uh i said it's you know it's
nothing like you know i said it's i take
antibiotics like
it's nothing like you can just dump it
out you guys know what is it
what is it and i said it's it's for like
you know if you know if
your stomach doesn't feel good or like
some type of indigestion but like you
know it's fine
it's just it's totally fine you can dump
it out i don't need it i'm telling my
donation
it's packed right i'm like you i do not
need that like throw it out right now
literally 10 feet away there's another
tsa agent just like typing on her
computer
and he goes becky becky
he turned into a brooklyn cab driver
from the 50s or the 50s
yeah he goes uh what is this love
bucky lucky he goes becky i think her
name was back yeah it had to be becky
he goes he goes becky
becky he goes pepto bismol what is it
what's it used for and she's typing she
just looks up she goes
diarrhea and then looks back at the
screen everybody he she
screamed diarrhea across this perfect
airport
he goes oh he goes would you be needing
it for your flight
i said no you can throw it away he goes
okay carry on
throws it away i zip on my bag turn
around who's right behind me the chain
[Laughter]
smokers
what are the odds the band the chain
smokers what are the odds that the
chains
are behind you in that moment that's
what it is i follow
an english man to the end of the earth
to the end of the english man might be
able to take me away from my family
100 percent so they fell asleep a woman
or a woman it's just the accent i mean
an english man
i should clarify all woman it's not the
man that's taking me away yeah but you
were saying you were a man
it's it's the english accent it's
something isn't it yeah and i got to be
honest with you any time when i was like
in a bar with my friends or whatever
like that like
growing up anybody who had a british
accent i almost wouldn't even believe
that i'm like you're putting on that
accent to try to get laid yeah you have
to prove to me
i would always ask but name me five
towns in london in england now name me
five towns
yeah and and and and then and then they
do it now london
bath london bath
sussex essex
newcastle sure there's so many yeah all
right you did it well uh people tend to
think of foreign accents more
interesting and more sexy says guy wench
a psychotherapist from britain
who's long based in the united states
because in general we tend to value
what's less common
that's what it is by the way you and i
before the pandemic we were talking
about big time going
and hitting the road in england because
i told you that's always been a dream of
mine you've lived
you've lived that dream where you've
went all over england toward the
countryside
that's what i want to do with you those
are my those are
my main peeps out there man i love
england the british are the best
and i want to i want to do a solo
stand-up tour well we should tour
together tonight i'll come on whatever
because i just literally i'll just i'll
be your tour manager it doesn't matter
i've always in my life for some reason
i've had a dream and a want and i don't
know why where it comes from we can
absolutely have we can have maybe we do
like uh stand up stand up
figure something out i want to be for
some reason i want to go i will
we'll tape it we'll take the pill i want
to have patreon patreon i want to have a
fan base in england that's just
any anytime i get a message from
somebody from england that supports my
comedy you don't understand like i feel
like i'm living a dream i don't know
what it is maybe it's because
the british therapist said it's just
something that's not common i don't know
my only
uh my only dealings with fans out in
england is that they've all been
amazing exactly what you want they're
just amazing
they're just like really loyal
supportive
courteous yes like they they get it you
know they appreciate it
yeah i find they're they're more pure
like i just comedy fans yeah yeah
no it's beautiful shout out to england
shout out britain who knows the
difference between england and britain
shout them all out shout out great
britain shout out great bridge shout out
to the whole united kingdom brexit
shout out brexit shout out i'll i'll
even shut up exit even the republic of
ireland i know there's be
you know republicans everybody shout
them all out shout out belfast shout
them out
just shout out everything shout them out
shout out another place irishman
shout out uh shout out shetland shout
out shetland pony shout out to show
shetland which i just watched on netflix
murder mystery show
shetland unbelievable place half of it
they half of it people think belongs
in norway norway is another fascinating
thing we don't have enough time to talk
about it though norway had a problem
with the vaccine
what oh yeah like 30 people don't know
why just in norway though
you know i don't understand that there's
a lot of things in news i don't
understand lately i don't understand the
gamestop
thing that happened you don't understand
that not really i mean i think what
happened there with gamestop is just
a bunch of nerds came in and just drove
up the stock price
of gamestop how here's what i think
happened all right
i'm going to take a crack at trying to
explain this yeah do you know what
shorting a stock is
i bel i yeah i i'm a fi i'm a major in
finance
but uh no i don't so we're shorting the
stock years ago
you you buy it so what stock
what hedge fund and i'm probably going
to kill me on the comments for this but
we're going to take it
buy it when it hits a certain you put in
an order i think what what hedge fund
people do
is they they purposely control the media
and the narrative and say
this stock sucks sell it it sucks and
they drive the price all the way down
some cycle saying forget this stock it
sucks don't buy the stock bubble
it sucks suck sucks and they drive the
price of it all the way down
knowing that they're gonna buy it when
it's really low and then change the tune
and drive it all the way up and make so
much money to change the tune it's just
it's a bunch of people descending on the
stocks yeah it's a coordinated attack
exactly the hedge fund people so what
happened with gamestop i believe
is the game they were trying to short it
out they were going to short it out the
same hedge fund people
like uh the ceo of robin hood which is
like the investment like they're all
hedge fund people
they were going to short suck they they
controlled the narrative a lot of times
they went out we were like no no someone
else is going to control
they were like they basically came on
the air one day last week and i don't
know where about you know what [ __ ]
gamestop
but they but they don't realize they
picked the wrong you don't mess with
game stuff you don't mess with computer
video game nerds
so they tried to short game stop
thinking let's drive this price low low
low
then we're going to say game stops the
future and blah blah blah you know in a
year from now and we're going to drive
it right back
like inside of trading though right but
hedge funds hedge fund people get away
with it but that that's what it is this
is the david vs goliath story it's
something that
goliath would always do you know these
hedge fund billionaires so what happened
was which they didn't account for is the
gamestop people
the game the people who love gamestop
the guys playing their video games
whatever banded together
on a reddit forum and said everybody buy
gamestop right now we're gonna lose it
drove the price up from 14 to like four
hundred dollars
somebody who had fifty two thousand
dollars of shares of game stuff
overnight twenty one million that's
insane
yeah so what does that person have six
feet of royal is he done now is it
nobody has that
that's true siegfried fishbacher and roy
horn yes yes i spoke out of turn i'm
sorry
i swear to god though but now what does
that perk doesn't he have to dump all
that to make that money back if it falls
back down
no isn't in essence he doing the same
thing because now he's going to dump it
all
well no well that guy no he could cash
out all right cash out right now get
make 20 million dollars you can't just
cash out someone has to buy it no
no right now it's worth 340 so if you
shell that sell the shares of it
he would get the money that means
someone has to buy the three well i
think they kind of unionized on reddit
and he's
everyone's agreed to hold that's why
they're holding the line
as a hey babe to the hedge fund guys
that's why they're holding the line
this is pretty much occupy wall street
except right
literally got it wow so it's 340. they
said they're about to do it with another
another amc i think amc because amc
is possibly going out of business or
nobody's going to the movies hurting
because nobody's going to the movies
which by the way practical joke was the
movie in theaters
during the when the pandemic hit i
remember i saw a shout out imc good
partner
i met paul abdul there it was great
didn't you did you did you i tried
i tried to i tried to i changed numbers
we changed the numbers to paul abdullah
you did you did it you did not you
did too i did but same thing happened to
me with paul abdullah as
jerry seinfeld i was told hey text me
anytime you want
left on left on red i do text with paula
but
i i you know my my introduction and our
relationship is a little bit different
than you meeting her that night i get it
but she's uh top-notch
classy gal yeah no i'll never forget i
was literally
at the impractical jokers uh movie
premiere after party i was standing
in between paul abdul on my right chris
cuomo on my left
uh was eating mozzarella sticks farted
put my plate down left
i never said goodbye to you chris cuomo
chris cuomo the
cnn news anchor chris cuomo was at your
impractical job no he was not
ask casey jost i didn't know that we
were making i was i
farted next to chris cuomo in the middle
of chris cuomo and paul abdul chris
cuomo was at your party
i i you can verify that with anybody i
don't know him i don't know how he got
there i'm uh
chris was fascinating chris cuomo you
know it was
you know there was so there's this
eclectic mix there and i know we
probably got it we're probably over time
eclectic mix but we had uh we had so
many people there we'll get into another
time we'll get to another time what do
you do what are you what are you going
to do
really because we don't want to go two
over we're going to two over and you got
big
yeah and you got big things you got your
your i mean because this here's the
thing
here's the thing we can't spend too much
time in this podcast because what we
need you to do
is go to true tv right now because the
impractical joker season 9 is out
i'll tell you another thing i need you
to stay tuned on true tv
because somebody else has a new show on
true tv
that's coming out listen to everybody
who watches that watches the show
and watches true you're going to be
seeing a familiar face on true tv
someone just got his own show on true tv
why don't we talk about a little bit we
got my own show on true tv i this is my
ninth pilot that i've done for for the
longest i've called myself chrissy
pilots
but now let's change that to chrissy
pickups that's the first pilot i've ever
done and been a part of got picked up to
air
it's called backyard bar wars with
christos stefano where i'm going to be
the host of two friends competing
in their backyards to see who's going to
build a bigger better cooler bar
and i just get drunk and we make fun of
everybody and each other the whole time
i i mean look if you know chris or you
don't know chris or you're watching this
and now you chris or whatever
you you know what chris does you know
what chris is gonna do what chris does
on that show so the show
is secondary chris's commentary is first
and people are going to end up watching
that show
i wish i wanted to succeed i think it's
a cool idea but
there's no doubt in my mind let's just
let's let's just be honest
yes that show hinges that show is going
to be successful
because of you and your jokes and your
riffing and your commentary and your
personality
i appreciate it so i i say watch that
show if you want to see more chris
and do what he does thank you i
appreciate it because what true tv told
me was it said they were really excited
about this i said because you know
impractical jokers
is uh you know season nine you know
we're gonna go season ten we're gonna go
we're gonna go all these seasons they
said but you know we know it's been on a
while and they said you know we wanted
to have a show that encapsulates
uh upwards of 25-year friendship with
four best friends
pulling pranks on each other through the
streets of new york city and they said
we don't think
we think a show where you hosting with
two friends who don't know each other
building backyards
and you hosting that show from los
angeles is the exact
complementary show that's that says in
practical jokes without saying
impractical jokers
so that's why they picked it up they
said this is they said this is like in
practical jokers too and i said listen
watching the pilot
it's me it's me and two black guys
building bars
i said that looks just like four white
guys from staten island
who have been friends for 30 years to me
i said and that said that
we should have just called into
practical jokers too i actually said i'm
i'm excited to do the show but it looks
a little bit like joker so
and i do a podcast with sal and i don't
want to think that we stole your idea
do you know when it's going to be do you
know what it's going to be on but i
think in the summertime so it might it
might it be on like
maybe sometimes they use us to lean into
the planet that's the plan they want to
put ours on after you
the plan is right now we're going to
start filming in mar we're going to
start filming soon next month
and then hopefully first episode on in
the summer
july so you you might go out to la in
march and then i might go out to l.a
tomorrow because i'll be on
family feud dude when you go out to
family feud
we'll all and then we'll come out we'll
go we'll do the la podcast and we'll
hang out
that's right that's that's what we
should do that's a great idea yeah
actually i've been to la in so long we
should get on
we should go on all of our friends
podcasts if our friends are watching
with podcasts and we know you're
listening
brandon chomps podcast he's a huge fan
huge huge fan
yeah so that's it so and listen if you
want to see me if you want to see us
live stand up christy comedy.com
atlantic city we got coming up uh the
vogel in red bank new jersey those shows
are almost sold out go get them and then
phoenix arizona february 25th 27th
christy comedy.com
also my own podcast chrissy chaos
patreon.com christy comedy enjoy the fun
that's crazy that's it i mean look at i
mean look at what you got going on right
now because
come on man we're doing the truth tv
pilot in a pandemic and you're doing all
this in a pandyline
thank you bob and i'm having a baby july
4th due date i mean that's the least of
it but
great yeah 100 um uh yeah
i'm not on the road right now will be if
those dates will be on salvo
countercomedy.com
jokers is on tuesday night season 9 just
started uh 10 o'clock true tv misery
index is on thursday nights 10 30 tbs
uh hopefully dinner party will come back
and then uh
i talked about before text me on my
community app listen i still want to
talk about this community up at some
point
but i never do but and i should memorize
my own number but that's the show is we
always get to something we're never
going to talk about and keep people
waiting
i'm on a community app i get your text
718-260-6619
text me sometimes i answer but i always
give you information first
on the app uh that was fun absolutely
rip sig freedom roy
look out for the patreon don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe